y con nuestro segundo invitado del día
como ya adelantábamos vamos a hablar de
los ganadores del premio nobel de paz
2021 que fue otorgado a la periodista
filipina maría reza y al ruso dmitri
murátov por su lucha a favor de los
derechos humanos en sus países el comité
noruego del nobel destacó los esfuerzos
de ambos para salvaguardar la libertad
de expresión según el comité reza
cofundadora en 2012 the rapper una
empresa de medios digitales de
periodismo de investigación utiliza la
libertad de expresión para exponer el
abuso de poder el uso de la violencia y
el creciente autoritarismo a su país
natal por su parte el ruso murátov fue
en 1993 uno de los fundadores del
periódico
independiente no baja gaceta una
importante fuente de información sobre
aspectos censurables de la sociedad rusa
información que normalmente no se
menciona en ningún otro medio de
comunicación para ello ahora sí le doy
la bienvenida entonces alfonso armada el
ex presidente de la sección española de
reporteros sin fronteras gracias alfonso
por atendernos en directo américa en
francés 24 me pregunto la importancia de
que dos periodistas hayan ganado el
premio nobel de paz
bueno muchas gracias por esta llamada
esta entrevista para reportar sin
fronteras es sin duda un espaldarazo una
un hoyo para todos los periodistas que
se la juegan desde colombia hasta méxico
pasando por filipinas o por rusia o por
china hay muchos reporteros que por
contar la verdad se ponen en el punto de
mira en el caso de maria reza y dmitri
murátov la verdad es que se premia a dos
periodistas muy valientes que en un
entorno muy hostil se han seguido
empeñando y se siguen empeñando
encontrar la verdad así es alfonso
también como usted lo decía filipina y
filipinas y rusia unas libertades
restringidas no en cada país pues en
diferentes contextos qué tan difícil es
hacer periodismo en esos países además
el kremlin ya felicitó a murátov
paradójico no que lo felicité
apoyando a la libertad de expresión un
país como rusia sin duda es bueno yo
creo que tú tienes un ejemplo máximo de
cinismo político contemporáneo lo hemos
visto en el caso de naval ni este
disidente que fue intentado asesinar por
el propio heredero del café que fue
tratado en alemania y regresó su país
para enfrentarse a un juicio sin
garantías y ahora está sometido a las
condiciones de presión durísimas bueno
pues 'novaya gazeta' este periódico que
han premiado a su redactor jefe y
fundadora de mi timoratos ha sufrido en
sus propias carnes el asesinato de seis
periodistas ayer mí mismo celebrábamos
15 años del asesinato de anna
politkóvskaya una de las periodistas
rusas de los últimos de las últimas
décadas más valientes que informó de los
abusos del kremlin en chechenia que el
propio putin felicité a este periodista
bueno es un acto de cinismo supremo
porque en rusia no hay libertad de
prensa y 'novaya gazeta' es una de las
pocas excepciones y en el caso de maria
reza bueno ella se ha enfrentado a un
gobierno impulsado por el presidente de
ute que ha convertido a la violencia y
el asesinato desde el poder en un arma
política y ha potenciado además desde la
policía el abuso para aparentemente
convertir el crimen maria riesch a se ha
enfrentado y se enfrenta a muchos acosos
judiciales a un intento de limitar su
libertad y por eso es tan admirable y
este premio de alguna manera es un
espaldarazo para ellos y para todos los
que trabajan en estas condiciones
más que el 75% de los países del mundo
tienen muchas dificultades los
periodistas para contar la verdad para
contar los abusos de poder y además a
premiar la valentía de estos dos
periodistas que a todos los que
trabajamos en este medio nos sirva como
ejemplo alfonso que también asada está
la libertad de prensa en el mundo sobre
todo digamos vamos a venirnos un poco a
nuestra región a la región de américa
latina y el caribe
bueno voy a aprovechar para hacer una
pequeña autopromoción porque hace tres
días llegaron a madrid cuatro
periodistas latinoamericanos un
periodista colombiano una periodista
nicaragüense un periodista cubano y una
periodista mexicana los cuatro están en
sus países amenazados en su trabajo por
precisamente hacer periodismo la
situación es muy inquietante lo estamos
viendo ahora mismo en el salvador con
una casa acoso sistemático por parte del
presidente bucl e hacia el faro y otros
medios de comunicación críticos lo
estamos haciendo en nicaragua con la
persecución sistemática de toda
vigilancia y de todo periodismo y muchos
periodistas nicaragüenses han tenido que
exiliarse a costa rica para poder seguir
trabajando volvemos en méxico donde
también son asesinados
prácticamente todas las semanas todos
los meses periodistas que intentan
contar la verdad y lo vemos en colombia
tristemente también donde a pesar del
proceso de paz sigue habiendo así
cientos de periodistas la verdad que nos
preocupa mucho porque estos periodistas
como muchos activistas sociales en su
propio ámbito intentan precisamente
enfrentarse al poder y trabajar en favor
de la ciudadanía es una tendencia que
nos preocupa mucho y que además la
pandemia antes hablaban de este asunto
ha servido también como pretexto para
que muchos gobiernos limiten más la
libertad de prensa así es alfonso ahora
más allá de la libertad de prensa hay
otra amenaza no en cuanto a la
información no clara la situación en
cuarto en cuanto a la desinformación que
circula a todos los días en las redes
sociales las noticias falsas que tanto
daño le hacen a nuestras sociedades
bueno creo que devastador y en ese
sentido además rusia es un campeón
precisamente en la desinformación con
muchos agentes dedicados a difundir
mentiras ya sembrar la discordia yo creo
que tenemos que volver a pensar y volver
un poco las esencias del periodismo
tratar de separar lo que es cierto pero
que es incierto internet es una
herramienta prodigiosa pero también muy
fácil para difundir de forma masiva y
con mucha facilidad en todo tipo de
infundios todo tipo de insultos la
verdad es que las pantallas los
ordenadores los teléfonos móviles
permiten que cualquiera pueda transmitir
cualquier cosa y da igual si es cierta o
no tenemos que volver a enseñar a
nuestros estudiantes a todo el mundo a
saber distinguir el trigo de la paja el
agua potable del agua tóxica y por eso
hay que aprender a ver el mundo a través
de internet y por los los ciudadanos
tienen que tener medios pues medios
rigurosos que traten de respetar
precisamente en la deontología
profesional separar la verdad de las
mentiras las opiniones de los hechos si
no estamos perdidos ahora quiero volver
al punto de nóvaya gazeta donde trabajo
murátov como hacen este tipo de medios
de comunicación para en países como
rusia países también pues diferentes a
rusia donde la libertad la libertad de
expresión la libertad de prensa de
prensa se ve restringida
pues apelando precisamente a algo que no
debería ser necesario
el periodismo en lugares como rusia como
china como mexico es casi un acto
heroico porque se enfrentan a una
presión constante en este sentido el
kremlin utiliza todo tipo de
herramientas para sembrar la discordia
para introducir pues las falsas por
ejemplo como pasó recientemente un
periodista 'novaya gazeta' y otras
periodistas de introducir por ejemplo
drogas en un coche de pues acusarle de
ser un drogadicto difundiendo vídeos
completamente falseados bueno la verdad
que es admirable y por eso este premio
de alguna manera nos permite que la
sociedad internacional esté más atenta
de lo que ocurre en rusia y es una
especie de salvoconducto no es no quiere
decir que la represión y los ataques a
libertad de prensa vayan a desaparecer
en rusia pero bueno de alguna manera
pone a nóvaya gazeta en primer término y
hace que la sociedad internacional que
la tenemos unidas en europea estén más
atentas pero desde luego lo que esto
significa es que ser periodista en rusia
como serlo en china como serlo en
filipinas demuestra que hay que tener
unas grandes dosis de valor
pues de alfonso gracias por estar con
nosotros en directo américa un placer
haber conversado con usted sobre este
tema además celebrar que dos periodistas
fueron premiados con el nobel de paz por
la labor que hacen y todo que hacían y
todavía siguen haciendo alfonso gracias
muchas gracias un abrazo desde madrid
ahora sabes de bogotá